les gens se déplacer avec les compagnies
forestières à se promener dans
territoire la chasse clac la nouvelle
élue d'un conseil de bande attikameks
patrick boivin connais bien l'histoire
de sa communauté
son grand père était chef quant au moa
chine était que camps de fortune au
nord-ouest de la tuque les autochtones
vivait alors comme si le québec
n'existait pas un isolement à la fois
volontaire est imposée jusqu'au 2 mai
1969 les premières nations n'ont pas
même le droit de voter les choses ont
bien changé reconnaît le conseiller
même si le 1er octobre dernier il a fait
comme ses ancêtres il est resté chez lui
pour être honnête avec vous logis même
pauvreté
j'ai pas voter pour les élections irie
suisses ont un peu métier comme tu dis
que si c'est toujours la même la même
histoire
il n'est pas le seul à wemotaci un
électeur sur dix a voté aux dernières
élections
en fait cinquante ans après l'obtention
leur droit de vote la plupart des
communautés autochtones participe très
peu au scrutin provincial
cette indifférence à la politique
québécoise le chef de wemotaci
l'expliquent avant tout par l'histoire
des peuples aborigènes prend un peu de
papier et web du mans moto x ou encore
cheikh l'os iphone
il n'empêche que le taux de
participation aux élections fédérales
est beaucoup plus important selon
élections canada il était de 62 % à
l'échelle la fédération en 2015
c'est au québec que les autochtones se
sont le moins déplacés avec un taux de
participation de 41%
le tableau n'est guère plus reluisant
pour ce qui est de l'engagement
politique
le péquiste alexis one who what a été le
seul autochtone a siégé à l'assemblée
nationale depuis l'obtention du droit de
vote des premières nations en a qui
disent cependant pour participer à ces
élections alors que d'autres vivent
il faut participer il faut changer les
choses à l'intérieur
ottawa demeure l'interlocuteur
privilégié admet le grand chef constant
awashish d'autant plus que les services
offerts dans les communautés comme la
santé il
éducation relève d'abord du gouvernement
fédéral au conseil la naissance km j'ai
prononcé à ça représente 6 % du budget
total
c'est pour beaucoup pour créer un
sentiment d'appartenance avec le québec
et établir des liens avec le
gouvernement provincial ou et mochis
peut compter sur sa proximité avec un
centre urbain comme la tuque et sur le
français parlé par la majorité des
membres de la communauté dans la langue
maternelle demeure latika mec c'est pas
parce que les gens votent pour un
communautés autochtones qui sont
apathiques martin papillon spécialiste
des questions autochtones croit qu'un
changement s'opère lentement mais
sûrement
surtout chez les jeunes - isolé grâce
aux nouvelles technologies mais dont
l'attachement aux provinces demeure
limitée on devrait être sensible comme
québécois mais à la volonté de maintenir
la langue l'identité le lien à l'endroit
où on vit puis paradoxalement on en sait
très peu au québec pour les autochtones
une relation n'est pas une voie à sens
unique rappel la nouvelle ministre des
affaires autochtones sylvie d'amour il
ya un effort de notre côté mais c'est à
eux aussi de participer au niveau du
vote la même chose c'est grâce au
développement économique que les
autochtones prendront leur place au sein
la démocratie québécoise estime la
ministre
d'autant plus que l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles demeurent une
responsabilité provinciale
je pense que c'est c'est de la confiance
il faut bâtir c'est du respect qu'on
doit avoir de nation à nation plus d'
écoute
voilà ce qui encouragerait patrick
boivin à se déplacer le jour du scrutin
un gouvernement qui me parle on noté
j'ai jamais sincèrement j'ai jamais
pense comme quoi il ne suffit pas
d'avoir le droit de vote pour vouloir
l'exercer ici à lesbos nos radios canada
à wemotaci au nord-ouest de là dessus